I don't have any of the traits we've talked about
in this lesson, but I'm not sure if I'm a carrier.
>> Well, there're a lot of recessive traits
out there that you could be a carrier for
that, we just haven't even had time to talk
about. Like hemophilia, phenylketonuria, Tay-Sachs disease and many more.
>> How would somebody like myself, or somebody
else find out if they had any of these?
>> Well, you'd actually have to be tested for each of these
conditions individually. But there are genetic
reports from companies like 23andMe and
Counsel that provide information on carrier status for many of these traits.
>> So if you're comfortable, and if you know, why
don't you tell us if you have any monogenic traits.